sont pas des revenus et la voilà deux
ans il apporte aussi bien avec lui je
vous donne tout pourquoi cinq essais lui
sa tentative wallonie moscou quand tu
sais que c'est lui dit tu donnes des
pouvoirs
vous avez roulé combien de kilomètres
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
rosa ou
et ça fait combien de courses et aller
m
on vous a déjà gagné
le premier joue le plus tôt est
en 1600 balle ils ont forcé les puits en
fait
ici aussi on devine à trois roues
quoi ils ont fait face c'est en
septembre je suis ont tous ces temps ci
la formation ils sont venus ils font
l'objet des civilisés ça on est dj 22%
de match et d'affaires d'accor donc la
réduire à 1
30 et 40 euros et vu que moi je suis
jeune entrepreneur j'ai entre 18 et 25
ans ont peu bénéficié d'une aide et j'ai
bénéficié du coup c'est utilisé par deux
suspects 11%
je dois y aller désert
j'attendais toujours ses gains de temps
ça peut peut-être faire un coup comme
celle là et c'est qu'on a tous je mets
salut
déposez une pousse ça me fait bien comme
ça
je n'ai pas besoin
compliqué
vous avez des clients très généreux ou
super sympa
ouais elle m'a dit pas c'est là
yariv celui et épatez vos sites en
europe
il a révélé dans son combat
de contenter marie mai ces combats
semblent soulagés après mauvaise foi par
la maison
ça arrive parfois que les clients et 60
avec nous il nous en faudra six tués
une danse en lames en bois radio
qui sont en général
il ya des clients qui sont cette hantise
en sympathie
[Musique]
moi
vous allez vivre avec lui en fait
puis six fois
s'il faut il former appel c'est une [__]
à lemaitre d'essence ils ne montrent pas
jeanne soit ramené ses plages et vous
appelle si vous descendez
peut-être que je suis déterminé testot
j'y arrive
si j'ai pas vu je vous rappelle il ya
peu
c'est la tâche
à un moment il ya d'autres ne veulent
pas
c'est ça qui fait réaliser que c'est
tous les clients descendez vous pourriez
faire combien de courses en plus
- ca pas aussi le mans t il raison
un peu par quinzaine et s'est pas trop
fatigué comme ça je t'avais l'eau forme
un épuisant
pratiquement nulles à écuissés dit-il
sympa la pratique ça fait maintenant
plus de temps et moins d'argent